we refer to the asymptotes I did talk
about them but I didn't talk about well
how do you get them okay it's not that
hard you can't just think about you
can't just think about limits and in
some sense that's what I'm going to do
but you can also have a formula pressure
just watch what happens how do I get an
asymptote like if I gave you some some
random rational function something like
something like this
okay how would you go about working the
asymptotes out for that whether they are
horizontal or oblique well first
question of a horizontal or oblique it's
not your question that's gonna work okay
they're horizontal
we'll spend more time on this later the
easy way you can tell it's horizontal is
that the degree of the numerator is less
than the degree of the denominator so
think what our horizontal work they got
some talks about they have nothing to do
with the center of the graph it only
about the edges which is writing cross
up with any of it right but as X
approaches infinity which one takes over
the numerator the denominator answer
could denominator big time doesn't
matter if there's like a million of
these guys on the top okay
the x squared will always take over in
the lowland right so okay so as X
approaches infinity right y approaches
zero so fine okay so now in order to
work out therefore what's happening in
this scenario okay I need to get it in a
form where I can say Y is equal
something so then I can see how it's
behaving
okay so this is kind of not a very
useful form to put it in so let's make Y
the subject
is that okay I've just switched around
the y squared on B squared and the one
just okay so now I guess I would divide
trying to be split
I was divided through by B Square okay
and what I got
sorry what are them I'm also my
shouldn't okay now why do I should take
that should take square it we should
nice so now by the way you're gonna get
plus or minus but do you see what that
signifies because you've got to use the
plus then use the - so no big deal I'm
gonna be naughty I'm just gonna write
down one of them okay don't kill me so
consider this case and they just slap
the minus sign on it for the otherwise
okay now this is okay it's okay but I
can do a little better than this right
I'm trying to work out what happens as X
approaches infinity because at the
moment as I consider X to infinity it's
not a useful result so limits are useful
when you've got things that vanish off
to infinity or 0 right so that's why I
take out this guy okay watch what
happens right if I took out X square and
a square becomes X on out the front
yes so what's this that becomes 1 and
this becomes because I divided I divided
so that's
okay now can you see where the limits
going right cuz as the limit as X
approaches infinity this sky what
happens to it disappears so you just get
a square root 1 just 1 so you're
approaching this which is a straight
line namely your asymptotes okay happy
with that so you actually can't just
read off 25 enjoy